what I told her was put Brands into your
content for free and then watch how many
Brands including those Brands start
coming to you so many creators think
that they're not going to put a brand in
because they're not going to give away
for free what they do when in reality
it's the reverse I think you have a lot
of control of what you want to happen
you can DM every brand in the world and
say not well you do work with me you
could just say I like your product keep
up the good work you know the stuff I do
you know how people screenshot like me
saying hi you could do that you could
say hi to the 50 brands that you think
are the coolest just literally I'm a fan
of your product and two of them are
going to reach out to you if nothing
else get some free samples of your
handbags you like you know so hi
everybody thank you for coming nice to
meet all of you
um
let's get you in here
yeah
thanks for stopping bye
thanks for having us yeah for sure look
honestly I I want to bring you as much
value as possible in the the biggest way
I think that can happen is to answer
anything that could possibly be on your
mind and I'll try my best so maybe when
you ask your question you can give me a
little context of yourself
um but I'm really happy you're all here
and I hope everyone's well
yeah
anybody want to start
damn
what's your name Natalie I met you yes
yes I remember
um
so my question is just around Brands
um now you know Target a younger or they
generally Target a younger audience as
an older Creator
um sometimes it can be a challenge so
where do you see older creators fitting
in and adding value going forward I I
think that that is more perception than
reality meaning yes but there's also
a scenario that that just is the reality
of the ratio because people that are
over 40 did not grow up in a manner
where they thought to be a Creator
because it didn't exist
we probably have more conversations with
Brands trying to reach to creators that
are not
of a under 35 year old demo so I
actually think that's perception more
than reality we see unlimited
opportunities we see it all day long it
just feels like that's where the media
attention is which is true and and
justifiable but I don't think that's
stopping your opportunity in any shape
or form
really I don't we see that pretty clear
globally and then I think for all of you
a lot of this is about taking things
into your own hands so I think creators
a lot of times do a couple things wrong
one they'd rather just get a manager or
something to represent them and because
they don't want to do business
development which I understand some
people are just naturally creative and
not business oriented number two
they don't integrate Brands into their
content day to day enough
you know I told something to a Creator
about a year and a half ago and she
emailed me recently and said she
couldn't believe how right it was she
said when you told me this I it made
sense she's like I didn't realize how
much sense it made until I did it what I
told her was
put Brands into your content for free
and then watch how many Brands including
those Brands start coming to you so many
creators think that they're not going to
put a brand in because they're not going
to give away for free what they do when
in reality it's the reverse
so I think you have a lot of control of
what you want to happen you can DM every
brand in the world and say not well you
do work with me you could just say I
like your product
like keep up the good work you know the
stuff I do you know how people
screenshot like me saying hi
you could do that you could say hi to
the 50 brands that you think are the
coolest just literally I'm a fan of your
product and two of them are going to
reach out to you if nothing else get
some free samples of your handbags you
like you know so so I think I think I
wouldn't worry about that because it's
not true brands are are more and more
trying to reach all ages all sizes all
shapes all demos
oh
um so I'm Sherry nice to meet you nice
to meet you maybe I'll provide some
quick context
um so I actually kind of wear two hats I
suppose the Creator hat is YouTube's my
main platform I do it for fun don't
necessarily have the intention to do it
the full time because what I actually
spend most of my time on is I actually
have a startup called rosters we work
with creators a lot makes sense um and
so basically we're a recruitment
platform for creators anything around
video editors from the designers script
writers producers and we're actually
just in our infancy stage right now
wrapping over Angel round precede but
what I have for you is obviously you've
built a very successful companies of any
lines of businesses across many
different areas and for us right now
like for someone who advocates for
creators to hire an Outsource because
the creative process is very personal to
what you do yes it's really difficult to
be like I want to hire a video editor
right now the only option is upwork and
Fiverr and have you ever tried hiring
someone on there you know that's like
swimming through an ocean trying to find
someone good of course so I always
advocate for creators to like try to
find the right people obviously and
Outsource it because you can't be the
biggest bottleneck of everything you do
but equally it's actually really typical
for our company ourselves as well as
such an early stage company to figure
out the right time to hire so it's more
of a business related question
action question yeah which is you
obviously have U.S operations Asia us is
our primary Market but how do you think
about hiring and scaling your team and
obviously opportunity costs and your
time is worth a lot you need to make
sure you hire at the right times but
I've also seeing an equal amount of
companies that have hired quite stupidly
fast and unnecessarily as well any
Frameworks yeah yeah it's a great
question I appreciate it um
so things have gone so well for me as an
operator for 25 years I started to get
very passionate about like what am I
doing different than or what are other
people that are building companies
consistently doing that I do there must
be some unlock to that truth and it's
funny you brought this up a lot of it
has to do with hiring
and so the framework I currently believe
in the most is hire fast
but this is where your Insight to hiring
fast and stupid is true hire fast
ER faster
and promote fastest
so let me break that down for you
the biggest mistake that people make is
not hiring
aggressively enough
the problem is too many people are
logical and they know they're guessing
when they hire which is true
I I have better intuition than 99 of the
world and I've hired nothing but tons of
bozos my whole career
it's hard
because it's not a real environment
you're hiring every person you hire is
putting a show on for you it's do you
know I've never called a reference in my
entire career why would I call the
people you told me to call to see if
you're good like as if you're gonna give
me somebody who you [__] up for like
hey John how's Susan she's terrible like
you know so high or fast because you're
gonna need to hire you're growing
especially once you raise some Capital
right
fire faster sometimes you know in a day
sometimes and you don't want to do that
to someone so what I started doing was
being upfront I'm like hey
what you could do is say hey we're
hiring I just want you to know My
Philosophy we've hire fast we fire
faster we promote fastest
so if you're bad Johnny
you may get fired in a month and you may
not want that on your resume store are
you sure you want this job
but hey Johnny if you're good you may
get promoted and hire your replacement
in six weeks
and so I think as long as you're
transparent up front
but I think most people don't fire fast
enough and the number one mistake that
people make is they don't promote fast
enough you hire a star
and you're like she's a star but you're
going to wait a year to promote her
because you're trying to save money but
she's a star
if she hears from you and you know if
she hears from you in a in seven weeks
hey you're getting promoted all of a
sudden she's someone that's going to
want to work there for a while and
that's what you have to do at a young
level because you have to build your
team your family your first seven eight
people is everything
it's why I believe in hiring friends
a lot of people I've never hired friends
or family I fully disagree on the other
way
again you have to be upfront with them
like hey best friend you might stink and
like your friendship matters more so
should we do this because this could you
know you have to over talk but that's
what I think you should think about
you're welcome
hi Gary my name is Kristen nice to meet
you for this year so a little bit of
context for you please
um you're currently studying in medical
school so yeah yes I'm also a content
creator as well so we are doing both yes
yeah so I've been watching your stuff
for like about a year and I want to say
a huge thank you thank you I think
online
um not many people can call me out like
that having a super real with your
content so thank you appreciate that
thank you I like a whole bunch of
questions
so I can't see which one is like
suitable but I think what's really
um relevant for me now you know so a
couple of creators here as well I'm
doing things myself and alone right now
yes so um for the past year or so my
numbers have like gone up significantly
on which platforms um Instagram okay
yeah so I I've heard you talk a lot
about you know pause reels Facebook and
all that yeah so I put that to work yes
see the numbers grow good about 3 000 uh
last last year about 100 over a thousand
now yes yeah so we've seen that growth
I'm thinking about taking an extent how
does that look like
um some things I have in mind going back
to YouTube long form how does that look
because for me I'm starting medical
school I don't have like the most time
to pull out like what you say 10 10
years a day yes yes right so I try to be
more effective I try to make every real
Count yes right and then now is the next
step right I'm at 125k you know I want
to take the next step how does it look
like
um I can make YouTube videos I started
on Vlogs actually I started doing long
form actually but I stopped and I
started focusing on reels now I'm
considering going back I can but every
time I do a YouTube video it takes me 10
hours but I can do 10 views for that so
I mean for businesses as well
um both Creator and a business right
would you advise doing long form is
there still a place for long form
there's always a place for long form but
everything's contextual given the fact
that you're committed to medical school
you're the last person I want to make
long for
me right because the truth is to your
point you answered it before I got a
chance
not only does it take you 10 hours
versus doing 10 posts
the results are not even close now now
you have a base so you can drive them to
the long form so unlike a year ago where
you would only get 47 or 470 views now
off your 125 you could get 10 000 views
but it's still small compared to the
awareness that you can get from your
reels
I believe in long form the most but I
also believe in being practical to the
reality of your situation of the moment
if you told me you graduated from
medical school and you're willing to
take a gap year to figure out if you
want to be in in the medical field or be
a Creator then I'd be more excited about
you doing long form because you have the
time and you should go all in to the
side but in your current state
I I think based on the way you told the
story you just like long form that's why
you started with it first
[Music]
um
100 right 100 and with that for a
business it helps to whatever tell a
story and all that so I'm thinking like
that's the next step necessarily look
like 200k for me or does it look like a
deeper Community you know I would go
with 200k because I think your width is
not that wide yet like 125k can a lot
easier be 540k in a year versus 120k
with long form might be 200k and deep
depth but the depth can be added at any
point and if you add depth to width
later I'd rather you start depth with a
million bass over here because you you
understand you're just you don't have
the capacity of time right now to make
such a commitment to long form that eats
up so much time
thank you so much you're welcome you
know what you might want to consider
vlogging through stories
so one thing that I wish I did that I
just don't do that I should do is Vlog
through my stories
I think vlogging through stories
continues to be a huge opportunity that
a lot of people don't take advantage of
people are using stories a lot of times
to drive awareness to other things but I
actually think it's a storytelling
platform within itself
and I think vlogging through stories
might be able to scratch your itch with
tasting a little depth while creating
far less
need for production value for it to be
capable it's even easier than reels it's
just vlogging through stories
something to think about
okay so I mean like posting on ideas
yeah whether IG whether I'll be honest
with you I think Facebook reels is such
a big opportunity for all of you that
nobody's seeing so maybe you're like
okay Gary said that I don't want to [__]
up everything else I'm doing but I'm not
doing any Facebook reels anyway so I'm
just going to Vlog through Facebook
reels you know I mean just blogging like
literally actually vlogging the way that
Casey neistat you know I came along and
created a different format when Dustin
used to be drock and I was being filmed
that was that was a new genre of someone
following you before me though it was
Casey and others actually vlogging with
camera in hand I think with an actual
camera like Dustin's I now think the
camera in hand as in your actual iPhone
vlogging and so you're putting out 71
stories on Instagram and it made a whole
story that day as a blog is a humongous
white space that more people should be
doing
thank you or on Snap
mm-hmm
which is very very very underpriced
attention in Asia
because a lot of people aren't doing it
thus the opportunity is there because a
lot more people are using it than people
realize
across the region
um and I think you know one of the key
you know talking points uh bus this year
is chapter yes
yes and how is it gonna change the game
for Content creation of the future yes
and I mean five years ago you were
really talking about podcasting yes
really became yes
yes
you know how AI is changing the game for
Content creators I think a I think AI is
underrated against its high powerbally
right now
I don't think people have really wrapped
around how big of a technology it is
I mean podcasting is a pimple on ai's
ass
it's a big deal
I would say many things one every one of
you should be playing with it
mid-journey you know chatting you need
to just taste it because it's like it's
almost as if this was 1997 I was like
you should just be on the internet you
should try it because it's going to be
too big for you to avoid it everybody in
this room everybody watching in this
camera will be massively affected by AI
for the rest of their lives it's only
going to get more significant not the
other way around so I think first all of
you should be just playing with it
second I think it's going to help a lot
of people like I can write effective
blog posts every day right now it's hard
for me to block written copy I have
somebody on my team poor McKenzie I'm
sorry Mackenzie she like she like wishes
I would talk to her
to make blog posts but I don't it's just
too hard I don't have the time for her
to interview me with with Chad gbt and
things like it I'll be able to write an
entire meaningful blog post by recording
I want you to write a blog post on why I
think Snapchat in in APAC is a good idea
for influencers especially if they do
Beauty and like I can like talk for a
minute and a half hit enter and
basically just send that to my team and
say just edit a little bit and have a
meaningful blog post every day all day
long
uh then there's also the creative
variable your thumb Mr Beast spends a
hundred thousand dollars to make a
thumbnail
Mr Beast spends a hundred thousand
dollars plus on thumbnails
long form YouTube do you understand that
in 12 months you can say something smart
into a generative creative AI bot that
will produce a better thumbnail than any
day of the week that Mr Beast can come
up with for a hundred thousand like this
is profound
so what do I think I think it's going to
completely change the world I think
every one of us me included and anybody
else who thinks a lot about more than I
even do are grossly underestimating it
it's going to be exponential and I think
everyone here needs to take it serious
because it's a huge opportunity
you're welcome
you're gonna ask you a question please
this is super cool
um everybody here has like amazing
questions they came prepared I'm a big
fan I've been following you for like
past six years now thank you a lot of
the content that you've put out really
shaped the way that I look at life on
gratitude perspective bad news and all
because of be friends I started my
journey in web 3 got the chemical
caterpillar which I eventually lost due
to a scam sorry to hear that held it all
the way to the reached like eighty
thousand dollars but
um
just want to say um my name is Daniel
Raja I'm a rapper musician from
Singapore assigned to Def Jam's
organization you know some music I've
been making music for about five years
now
and ever since I got signed like I got
signed at the very beginning of my
career so I never really got to explore
what does it feel like to be an
independent right right right and from
day one the challenge has been how do I
keep putting out music that aligns with
the labels plans at the same time build
my personal brand because the personal
brand is the world it's the thing that
brings in the cash like all these like
campaigns on Instagram of course paid
posts and whatnot in Singapore we don't
get that many opportunities to make
money off the music because of Spotify
what
um advice do you have for artists like
myself that are trying to push the
personal brand on as many platforms as
we possibly can without feeling like we
are forcing it because I do find myself
feeling like how to say like a little
overwhelmed with the with what I have to
keep up with with Tick Tock and
Instagram and Twitter and all these
different forms that you've got to like
stay up to date and stay relevant
because I feel like all these people are
following me but if I don't post I feel
a little guilty that I'm not creating
that engagement and creating the
discussion on the bus or whatever
well I mean that goes back excuse me to
the things that you know the lovely
words you said to me when you started
which is as someone who's listened for
five or six years
this is not going to seem foreign to you
what I'm about to say is well if he
feels overwhelming or guilty like you
don't have to
you know like the reality of all of this
is if you can't do something that
genuinely makes you happy
it's not going to work out anyway
if you're doing it because you know you
should be doing it because you're trying
to build a career
but it's not enjoyable
that is not a sustainable model
ironically my piece of advice is to
maybe take a break
which seems like a complete curveball
for me but to me the concern is if
you're doing it
for the money if you're doing it because
you're like well if I'm not top of Mind
someone's gonna comment right
that comes from a place of fear it comes
from a place of Defense
you need to find joy in it
right and so one of the things I think a
lot about is
people are always trying to make content
that they think will work versus making
content that they want to make
it especially concerns me with people
that like you know what I get a lot of
questions about is people that grew
because they're attractive and they no
longer want to post naked pictures
not fully naked only fans I mean just
like like guys with abs or girls that
are wearing barely any clothes like you
get you like that one yeah it's gonna
it's gonna add on to like my next
question okay good so so you know you
know it's a very common question which
is like I'm now 27. I built four million
followers because of who I was as a 22
year old I don't want to do that anymore
what do I do and the answer is always
like stop doing it
like you know this you're asking a very
similar question with a slightly
different tweak which is
it's not gonna work if you don't like it
anyway
so maybe there's other things you could
be posting which is a thing that
everyone should be thinking about which
is like when I didn't want like I built
my career in 2006 on YouTube making wine
videos
and then I didn't want to and everyone
said I was crazy and every like when I
stopped making wine videos and started
making business videos Everybody in the
wine business told me that I was making
the biggest mistake of my career
because that's all I was known for I
just was building a wine business I was
one of the most followed and like
understood people in that era and
people are like what are you doing and
my comments were like why are you
talking about business just stick to
Wine like what do you like but I it
didn't even cross my like I started over
my engagement my view all started over
but I knew it wasn't going to work
anyway
you need to find something you want to
do
like you need to post
things you want to talk about
you know otherwise you can't be
sustainable
so what do I think I think you have to
make this work for your soul because if
you don't it's not gonna work out anyway
well I really enjoyed
how do I have to choose a certain like
platforms and then like just log in with
it or just look my my answer to this
question are two extremely opposites my
answer is everybody at this table should
be posting as many times as humanly
possible on every platform
comma
and I just told you that maybe you
shouldn't post for three months
you have to be self-aware of what you're
about
to maximize Commercial Success you need
to post on everything from LinkedIn to
tick tock to Snapchat to Facebook
Stories long form short form audio
written all of it
the amount of humans that can achieve
that are almost none it's hard
you could though but let me give you
another example there's a lot of people
at this table and around the world that
make a lot of money doing this and
should spend it by hiring four people so
they can make more of it that's what I
did
instead of keeping the money and buying
a [__] Bugatti I hired people and
made it bigger
so like everyone has to decide what
they're doing here
that's what you have to do
got you okay I'm gonna open the next
question okay hi Gary I'm a huge fan
thank you everyone else here
um I've been following you for many many
years thank you on your podcast
um actually my question interesting is
that young writer actually came out this
question it's kind of the opposite so
I've made a career for myself out of
doing personal training I started as a
fitness trainer when I was 18. I was on
YouTube and then it evolved to a show on
YouTube called No Sweat it's the First
Financial in Singapore and then I create
an app out of it called no sweat it was
great doing the covert period because
people were yeah yeah yeah so that was
great and I feel like I've built a lot
of my personality and my brand around
Fitness and Wellness
um
funny I've always loved music and my
passion has always deeply been to do
music and to be a country artist I love
it
two different extremes but I love
country music and I've always been so I
was a personal trainer in the morning
and I go to UNI and I'm a singer in the
evening so I just kind of did both
things Fitness and music now like since
last year I've realized that I really
want to delve into my huge passion which
is to do country music and music so I
started putting out my own originals and
what I feel and my fear is is that my
engagement will drop which I feel like
for when I start putting out music
people are like what is she doing you
know like why is she putting out country
music first she's like you know in the
gym like working out we have a red play
and then on one hand I'm not here like
playing the guitar and saying I can love
ballad
um which which I love um so my fear is
diluting the brand I think to add this
question like we love both things we
love what we do we love content creating
we I think that's the thing that we just
love too many things how do I do it
what's the advice from for someone who
wants to Rebrand but also doesn't want
to dilute their brand can I tell you
Their audience that she's downplaying
herself she like sings and she went on
the Michael Bolton competition yeah
[Music]
it's awesome so
I made content about business I make
content of me going and buying things at
garage sales
I make content about me in corporate
business environments for entrepreneurs
I make content about nfts and web3 I
make content about the New York Jets I
make content about eating blueberries I
think that people are incredibly
um not kind to themselves
you know like the thought that this to
your point even if you weren't great
people would just love you more if you
were an average country singer because
people
like people not just for one thing but
humans have gotten too philosophical
even the fact that you said I don't want
to dilute the brand humans now think of
themselves as product
you literally just sat here and said I
don't want to dilute the brand talking
about yourself
I think it's an insight to I understand
how you're thinking but the strength of
a human being that is much stronger than
Evian is that you're not a brand you're
a human being which means you're nine
brands
your strength is that your nine Brands
not it's your weakness
the problem is everyone has become so
addicted to a metric on a social media
that they are accustomed to getting that
it's stopping them from their happiness
people are not striving for their
happiness because they want to get an
average of 7 000 likes that they're
accustomed to they don't have the
courage to get 800 likes but be happy
so just be happy
right like if you think about it so many
of you have wanted to post something
else but you knew it wouldn't get good
engagement
think about how [__] up that is
right
meanwhile what you don't know is it's
probably the best thing you can do to
eventually get to double engagement
you just have that the courage to be
fully authentic in the short term
but it's so good I I desperately hope
that people figure this out and it's
been a core strength of mine my content
is all over the place
my Instagram grid doesn't look the same
you never know what the [__] I'm gonna
get get from me you really have no idea
what's gonna come out of my mouth of
course there's things I'm consistent
about about kindness or work ethic or
thing but like you you know like here's
nfts now and I when I'm ready I'll talk
about Ai and but you know like and so I
think
I think you have to allow all of you
have to allow yourself to be yourself it
is where your strength is
thank you
a quick question uh my name is Ethan I'm
a content creator uh I've been creating
content around food for the last few
years food I listen to your podcast on
the Diary of a CEO yes one of the most
uh impactful things you said was your
self-worth and identity is completely
detached from your person your
professional accomplishments yes and you
sort of based your
[Music]
about how your self-worth is predicated
on how you interact with another person
yes so as a content creator a lot of
what we put out is ourselves yes and
imagine for you as well how do you make
that Detachment and how did you land
that conclusion it's a great question
um so what you're saying I assume is
when you as a Content producer put
something out and someone is [__] on
you or it doesn't perform well how do
you let that not affect you
yeah for for someone like immensely
successful yes how do you say like I am
not my business I'm not these companies
that are doing myself but there's
nothing to do with that and you've given
an alternative answer which is that
myself what all my value is in my
interaction with the one-on-one the
person in front of yeah
because it's my truth you know to answer
your question it's because the reason I
think I'm successful is because of the
second part
you know I mean I
I think all of us have to really
recognize who we are you know for me
I genuinely am more passionate about
being a nice person than I am about
being a successful businessman
and so like but I just happen to be also
good at business like she just happens
to be capable of singing
that has nothing necessarily to do with
her capacity being an entrepreneur and
building a fitness app they're just all
these different dynamics that we all
have
I think what was powerful about what I
said on that podcast was I also knew
that a lot of people would be listening
to it
and it's been something I've been
thinking a lot about which is like why
am I so capable of being happy so often
why don't I have the normal
amount of anxiety when I have the
rationale to have way more anxiety
when you're being judged at the level
that I'm being judged when you are 47
and have lots of Dynamics in your life
at that point like when like there's a
lot going on in my life and yet
it's just all so quiet and so you start
asking yourself why and it's how I got
to that conclusion I'm like oh right I
just don't care
I don't care that I'm good at business I
don't think I'm special this is all very
nice
and it feels incredible to have people
say nice things following like
but I don't think it makes me special
I just don't
I think that's good parenting I think
that's luck of DNA I think there's a lot
of things going on there but I can tell
you that the faster all of you can get
there the happier you will be
how late did that come for you or how
early it it came so early
notice how I said the reason I think I'm
sick it happened before high school the
reason I liked high school so much was I
didn't give a [__] what people thought
of me that's really hard like it seemed
normal to me the reason I was such a
good businessman was I
did business instead of trying to be
popular
I did business instead of trying to get
good grades you know I was just in a
very
funny place my whole life I was just
always willing to be I was always you
know
the only thing I think I'm actually
great at
like truly is
being myself
you know and so I think like for all of
you it's back to what you just said like
if I could wish anything for all of you
besides health
it would be deep self-awareness
because once you know who you are you
can actually start to navigate the world
outside the framework of the world
this is why I talk a lot about buying
watches and like most people buy [__] to
project
not because they actually like it they
think they like it they don't understand
the bigger meaning they like the
affirmation they like the attention
they like the validation
they don't actually like it
they force themselves to like it as a
proxy to get what they wanted
hi yes
um so I'm Cheryl I
I too many pets I run a family business
I run my own brand I'm a mom of three
wow I uh incidentally I've been creative
content as well so something I've
learned from you is to love the process
so there's something that has kept me
for many many years so two questions
um one question is I think sometimes we
overthink or rather how do we deal with
content fatigue yeah be it for business
or for personal
um because my interest is in wellness
it's in motherhood it's in
um you know Health but then again
I feel like I put all these out there
you know or like maybe my previous
eating disorder I put that all these out
there but
how much more can I talk about it again
because I've said it you know so content
fatigue is one and the second question
is uh relating to
you know I think uh you know being happy
right like having so many heads I feel
that sometimes it's very overwhelming
and it's very stressful how do you kind
of just have all these yeah this quiet
and all this noise two things so the
first thing
on the content fatigue
the question I would ask all of you is
who are you making the content for
my belief is that most people are making
the content for themselves
and what they want out of it the reason
I don't have content fatigue is because
I get great joy out of making the
content for all of you
so for me I'm capable and my friends ask
me this all the time aren't you tired of
saying the same [__] over and over and
I'm like never for example for some of
the people here that have been consuming
my content I think this will resonate
there's been things that really if you
think about the three best pieces of
content that I've ever made for you
I bet you you'll realize once I say this
that you had heard me say it 19 other
times prior to that it was just that you
were ready to hear it that time
so for me when you've got as powerful of
a story that can help so many young
women like actually being vulnerable and
authentic about having an eating
disorder you could talk about that every
day for the rest of your life because
you know on the other side there's some
girl in Stockholm right now that needs
it
so for a lot of you content fatigue
comes from the fact that it's selfish
not selfless
that's not bad I have plenty of selfish
wants and needs too but I think the
reason you can easily get to a place of
not having content fatigue is similar to
what resonated for you about loving the
process once you make all of your
content
for the sake of the person on the other
side of it you'll never stop
so that's one place to think about
the second ones ironically the complete
reverse answer
the thing that you need to do with
overwhelming is to be kinder to yourself
with all the hats that you're wearing
especially mothering three children
all of us beat ourselves up too much
that's where you need to be very selfish
a place where everyone needs to be the
most selfish is in the way they love
themselves
the the way things are quiet for me and
not overwhelming is I'm my biggest fan
but not in a narcissistic egotistical
way in a I'm compassionate to me
you have to be nicer to yourself we're
human beings everyone every person in
here is going to do something stupid
today
I think I'm really good at stuff
business I'll make it narrow I think I'm
really good at business I'm gonna make
150 big mistakes this year having the
capacity to be kind to yourself and
predicate it on your effort
is everything
you know and that doesn't mean don't
hold yourself to a standard that means
just have more compassion to yourself
you're juggling a lot of [__]
family business brand three children and
content creator you've got a lot going
on you're allowed to have a bad hour
you're allowed to have a bad day you're
allowed to have a bad week month and
you're allowed to have a bad year
we just need to be nicer to ourselves
I'll I'll go a little faster good yeah
I'm Toby
Singapore so I painted a new outside in
your office
so that's by me and Ida employee of
yours so I think something I realized
along the way after I've done art for
the longest time is that when I first
started doing art on Instagram social
media it didn't get very fast it was
just like a portfolio and when I started
to realize that social media is called
social media and post that myself doing
that I mean things really took off from
there and I think that's also particles
of human stuff that you've shared and I
think brand just noticed that and
starting to do a lot more brand
collaborations more fun decoration as
well
it's cool
so I think one question I've been asking
myself more is that art is how I got
started and the thing that I really
loved
but at the same time with the content
creation
I still do enjoy that as well but
I'm struggling I guess it was an
accident to find that balance between
the two something that I really love
doing yes yes
I think you need to fight more for the
love and not the money right
that's it okay Okay the reason you're
struggling is you recognize the
commercial opportunity but you only have
so much capacity and it's taking away
from the thing you like
and this goes back to a lot of the theme
of today just you you have to understand
balance is subjective and not true there
is no balance there's your feelings and
opinions on balance
so it just sounds like you need to tweak
it a little bit back to a little more
time for you to do art like for example
you can make a simple rule for yourself
that no matter what on Monday coming out
of a weekend to get the week going right
you do art
the world made up that we work five days
a week and have two vacation days but
you can make up that you have two big
two weekend days one art day and four
work days you just have to create the
framework that will work for you right
now based on what you're saying is
you're starting to hit that inflection
point where you realize the the
commercial side of you is eating into
the you know the essence of you and you
just need to find a little room for it
all right thank you I think my question
is actually go ahead please
anyway I'm a photographer I do study
Hong Kong and conventional photos like I
don't just shoot I shoot creative
architecture photos with like humans and
stuff so it's like I
um take my craft as a pride yes so I
always get confused not confused like
stuck in between like content like the
crowd that I do and also the trend that
people actually do of course for example
like you know I do photography and I'm
an advocate from about photography
because I shoot a lot of mobile and like
you know people always think like
otherwise like oh wait you should be
some mobile phones and stuff but I think
it's like there's a lot of tips for
mobile phones that I know myself and the
trend is always like to teach people and
photographic tips but the things like
I'm always stuck into not sure I post my
craft or should I actually post rules in
my photography teams well what do you
want to do well I kind of like always
like to post the craft but in like
posting wise and encourage that post
doesn't always work as good it's like
Photo like all right I'm aware yep so
it's like I'm always just stuck like you
know should I just post the crap or like
should I actually do like so the world
like translating which give me numbers I
understand I understand
the world
for some [__] reason the world is
addicted to the word or
and so much happiness can be found in
the word and
the answer to your question is
both
right like think about how simple that
is it's like should I do this or should
I do this what you just said when the
reality is the the social media
Platforms in the world is this whole
table
you can easily do both there's room for
all of it
you're not compromising one or the other
this is where people got into silly like
silly scenarios where like you better
not post this because it's going to [__]
up the algorithm
remember that
like it's all silly [__]
both
this is why this is why a lot of what I
just talked about is going to work
you're not gonna you can you wanna post
a country song and then the next day a
workout video good
like the capacity for and is
unbelievable
I think in a sense where like the trend
like you know photography teaches like
if I keep doing that both like I mean my
crop and photography tips like what sets
apart from me and I didn't create this
way HD also post the same thing why are
you worried about the setting apart
what's going to set you apart is you're
different
we're all set apart
right to your point it's a really
interesting question the amount of
people that do things because they think
in scarcity
not abundance
you believe that you let you doing
something similar to other people does
not have enough capacity for both of you
to eat
I think everyone's doing the same [__]
there's seven million people doing the
same [__] you're doing every one of you
there's thousands of people that wait
for me to post something and just make
their own version of it an hour later
and it's still not taking away from me
it drives my team crazy sometimes
they're mad at people but like
yeah there's no scarcity in that you
understand
yeah even like you have to understand
like the adjective you use in your copy
like the adjective
that's different than someone else's
adjective already makes you different
okay
thank you so much everyone I appreciate
you guys